je commence donc avec l'avenir de
l'audiovisuel public privatisation
suppression de la redevance les
candidates et les candidats ne manquent
pas d'idées samia de sheer pour redonner
du pouvoir d'achat aux français emmanuel
macron s'engage à supprimer la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
plus connu sous le nom de redevances
elle est payée en même temps que les
textes d'habitation par tous les foyers
qui déclarent posséder une télévision on
supprimera des impôts qui reste la
redevance télé en fait partie c'est
cohérent avec la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation faut aller au bon sur les
3,7 milliards d'euros de budget de
l'audiovisuel public
3,2 milliards sont financés par cette
taxe est pour l'instant emmanuel macron
ne précise pas comment ils comptent
combler ce vide c'est précisément ce que
lui reprochent valérie pécresse elle
aussi favorable à une suppression de la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
cette redevance c'est une taxe qui a
fait son temps qui est à ce qui est
obsolète dans son mode de perception et
dans son assise mais le problème c est
ce que nous voulons garder un service
public est ce que nous voulons garder
une création audiovisuelle française est
ce que nous voulons continuer à être
relancée et donc il va falloir la
finance et il va falloir sécuriser le
budget de la création audiovisuelle en
france avec je crois une loi
pluriannuelle
à l'extrême droite marine le pen et eric
zemmour veulent aller plus loin qu'une
suppression de la redevance et propose
ni plus ni moins que la privatisation de
l'audiovisuel public moi je peux pas que
les français payent pour une radio et
une télévision qui font de la propagande
anti française immigrationniste lgbt et
homo comme on dit aujourd'hui donc
j'estime que nous supprimerons la
redevance et nous supprimerons et nous
privent attiseront france 2 et france
inter à gauche au contraire les
candidats défendent de financement de
l'audiovisuel public par les
contribuables à l'image du communiste
fabien roussel ma proposition c'est pas
de supprimer la redevance parce que je
considère que nous avons besoin de
défendre une télévision publique une
radio publique pour qu'ils investissent
dans des programmes accessibles à tous
et qui en même temps diffuse mois de
publicité yannick jadot et anne hidalgo
veulent tous les deux pérenniser la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public jean
luc mélenchon lui serait prêt à
l'élargir aux détenteurs de smartphones
et de tablettes
faut-il supprimer la redevance
audiovisuelle et au delà quel avenir
pour le service public en france voilà
le thème de notre débat j'accueille
catherine morin desailly bonsoir à sera
bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice unis de
seine-maritime mathieu guidère ici la
triste liste centriste et les centristes
c'est comme ça qu'on dit maintenant très
bien mathieu gallet président de
magellan bonsoir bonsoir plate forme de
podcasts ancien président de radio
france évidemment on va accueillir jean
marc dumontet dans un instant qui est
producteur de spectacles référent
culture du candidat emmanuel macron
matthieu croissandeau bonsoir mathieu
surtout heureux de vous retrouver
éditorialiste politique avec nous
également en duplex en visioconférence
christophe koszarek grand soir
christophe koszarek vous êtes président
gérard wade président de la fédération
des créateurs audiovisuels et numériques
et on va être transparent avec nos
téléspectateurs on se connaît bien
puisque vous avez produit pendant des
années unis millions une émission qui
s'appelait médias le magazine que je
présentais donc vous connaissez bien ces
questions de d'avenir de l'audiovisuel
merci à tous d'être là peut-être votre
état d'esprit face à cette proposition
du candidat emmanuel macron catherine
morin desailly bonne ou mauvaise idée
c'est le prolongement de l'ensemble des
annonces qui ont été faites pendant tout
le quinquennat d'abord la promesse d'une
réforme qu'on a mis longtemps à voir
venir et qui a été tout d'un coup
annulées bien sûr il ya eu la crise du
cabinet qui a stoppé le processus
législatif mais jamais il n'a été repris
par ailleurs donc une promesse non tenue
de réforme de l'audiovisuel dans toutes
ses dimensions le modèle économique la
question la redevance la contribution à
du vfb c'est son vrai nom mais aussi une
réflexion sur les missions l'audiovisuel
public la gouvernance la modernisation
la numérisation de l'ensemble des
entreprises et donc cette promesse n'a
jamais été tenues et depuis le début il
n'ya eut dénoncé que des
mesures budgétaires tout s'est fait à
travers le budget jamais sur une
réflexion sur les missions de
tunisiennes publiques sur le périmètre
de l'audiovisuel public bref ce qui fait
d'abord pour moi le préalable comme
aujourd'hui la vraie question c'est de
savoir doit-on ou non maintenir à
l'audiovisuel public je pense vraiment
que oui je suis si vous décrochez
finalement sujet président-candidat
saïfi propose simplement de supprimer
alors est ce que tu veux dire la
redevance ici on s'en dire il fallait
que quoique faire ça parce que l'eau
divisé le public sont plusieurs centres
eu prise c'est la gestion des archives
ce son orchestre de de radio france
c'est notre audiovisuel extérieur sont
nos journalistes sur le terrain en
ukraine un travail formidable donc que
c'est toute une série de sujets
d'ailleurs qui méritent d'être mis sur
la table et débattu devant les français
qui d'ailleurs pour une grande partie
d'entre eux quand on regarde les son bac
il y en a eu plusieurs de fait à 85% les
français reconnaissent un rôle
particulier oui ils sont attachés aux
services nous livre enfin sur la
question est-ce que vous
je suis
bien content dans un instant mathieu
gallet ancien président de radio france
donc forcément votre avis et éclairé sur
sur cette question comment vous avez
réagi en entendant le président de la
république faire cette annonce alors je
vais j'ai réagi comme un ancien un
ancien poste que j'ai occupé et
catherine morin desailly s'en souvient
puisque j'étais conseiller en charge des
médias de la mise la culture en 2008
quand nicolas sarkozy avait annoncé lors
d'une conférence de presse de rentrée à
l'elysée à la surprise générale de la
ministre elle même et donc de son
cabinet qu'il supprimait la publicité
après 20 heures ni sur les antennes de
france télévisions c'est julia remis à
patrick de carolis qui était le
président de france télévisions était
absolument pas au courant mais c'est une
bombe le président candidat a lancé en
annonçant prenant un peu tout le monde
de court même si vous votre reportage
l'a montré et à eghezée mourou marine le
pen avec d'autres arrières pensées
qu'ils assument d'ailleurs très
clairement de privatisation partielle de
l'audiovisuel public mais effectivement
c'est la même c'est la même bombe qui
est lancée en coupe le financement de
radio france france télévisions lina
arte et
tv5 monde
france 2 et france inter et donc dix
mois ça me rappelle effectivement se
souvenir de l' annonce surprise de
nicolas sarkozy le 8 janvier
affaiblissement quasi mécanique ou pas
forcément moi je pense qu'on fait en
commençant par
le la question du financement est on est
en campagne et pardon du manthey peu ne
peut nous rejoindre si bien d'arriver
pardon en interrompant on est en
campagne électorale et donc je ne suis
pas surpris en fait qu'on annonce une
mesure qui apparaît comme une mesure
effectivement de pouvoir d'achat de
supprimer 138 euros en métropole 88
euros dans les outre-mer mais au fond on
va couper d'un côté ce qu'on sera bien
obligé de retrouver de l'autre puisque
ces trois milliards 8 il faudra bien les
sinon c est donc quelque part les
français leur financeront aussi parce
que effectivement je rappelle les
chiffres ces 138 euros ça touche 27
millions 600 mille foyers ça rapporte 3
milliards 2 net c'est ce qui est prévue
en 2022 mais l'état rajoute 600000 donc
ça fait 3 milliards 800 millions oui 600
millions jean marc dumontet
on le le bon vous étiez là pour les
premières minutes mais vous comprenez
bien le l'enjeu l'enjeu de la
fragilisation et de l'avenir du service
public on a eu le sentiment en écoutant
le président que bon c'était
effectivement une mesure fiscale quelque
sorte de pouvoir d'achat mais qui avait
pas les annonces attendues sur qu'est-ce
qu'on fait du service public en france
alors on va recontextualiser way
première prise de parole du candidat à
poissy
c'était pas le projet culture qui était
développée quand même important on est
d'accord et à cette occasion le
président effectivement dans la logique
de la fin de la taxe d'habitation parce
que ça me fait penser un peu aux
prélèvements la source si vous voulez on
sait qu'il ya la fin de la taxe
d'habitation voilà 80% des français on
en bénéficier 100% à partir de cette
année donc on sait qu'il ya un problème
qui se posera à tout le monde c'est
comme le prélèvement à la source tout le
monde savait que ça allait se faire
personne ne le faisait et puis on l'a
fait et ça c'est bien fait bon et ça
avait suscité beaucoup d'inquiétude
beaucoup d'interrogations et c'est
quelque chose qui s'est passé
naturellement j'entends ne pourrait
maintenir la contribution à la redevance
tout en supprimant non parce qu'en terme
de recouvrement ce n'aurait pas de sens
en termes de coût de recouvrement ça
n'aurait pas de sens c'est le premier
point s'est déployé beaucoup de gens
pour récupérer 138 euros vraiment ça n'a
pas de sens c'est le premier acte 2e -
elle adossé à une autre taxe ba a priori
non deuxièmement c'était
dans la logique de la fin de la taxe
d'habitation donc ça c'est important et
c'est une mesure forte de pouvoir
d'achat un moment donné où le pouvoir
d'achat est quelque chose de
significatif et c'est un un des axes du
président donc il faut d'abord le
contextualiser
c'est une mesure de pouvoir d'achat
effectivement cette mesure de pouvoir
d'achat elle n'est pas neutre elle
suscite des interrogations elle suscite
l'interrogation du financement du
service public le président vous savez
c'est pas quelqu'un qui fait les choses
en catimini et qui dissimulent les
choses il est plutôt accusé généralement
d'être un peu trop vrai de dire un peu
trop vite les choses et de parfois ne
pas ménager ses interlocuteurs on lui a
beaucoup reproché cette fameuse phrase
sur l'audiovisuel public l'at-il
prononcé personne ne le sait mais en
tout cas elle est là elle a traîné
longtemps donc je pense que le président
ait quelque chose qui ne fait pas les
choses en catimini donc une chose est
sûre le président tient aux services
publics la phrase à laquelle vous faites
référence c'était quoi c'était la
république pas on est bien la corde de
la raison tient au service public le
président ne veut absolument pas
privatiser le service public le
président ne veut absolument pas pardon
du temps ne veut ou ne veut pas remettre
en cause le service public c'est très
clair aux d'autant plus à un moment
donné où la question de la souveraineté
est une question très est censée
justement ça va être vous le service
public au service public en termes
d'information coût en terme de création
en termes de d'irrigation avec les 500
millions qu'il apporte la production
française est essentiel dans un instant
soyez pas inquiets mathieu oui on
supprimons la redevance et mâcon
supprimer l'impôt c'est vrai que c'est
une mesure pouvoir d'achat mais il
supprime un des rares impôts fléchés et
c'est ça aussi qui explique tu voyais
toujours des levées de boucliers quand
vous en deux quand vous supprimez à
l'impôt fléché quand vous avez supprimé
la taxe d'habitation tous les élus
locaux qui ont commencé à dire capeb et
ce qui va se passer parce que c'était
fléchés pour pour les communes et et
comment ça va se passer et à chaque fois
l'état disent vous inquiétez pas on
compensera il faut aussi reconnaître que
par le passé sous différentes majorités
l'état n'a pas toujours compenser le
montant exact au fil des années que
rapportait l'impôt fléché à la base
c'est que c'est aussi pour ça qu'il ya
une réflexe qui est pas seulement
corporatiste mais car bref les
inquiétudes de la part de tous les
professionnels de l'audiovisuel public
qui se disent aïe aïe aïe si jamais on
n'a plus ses ressources attribuées
directement dans le projet de loi de
finances parce que c'est ainsi que ça ne
peut pas être autrement on va avoir du
mal derrière à convaincre peut-être un
autre gouvernement peut-être un autre
état d'où l'idée peut-être dunois
programmation pluriannuelle pour
inscrire les choses dans la durée mais
dès qu'on supprime oms afro fléché ça
c'est quand même très très symbolique
est alors justement aux bergers qui est
député la république en marge des
yvelines rapporteur général de la loi
audiovisuelle sur le financement de
l'audiovisuel public elle était cet
après midi on l'a sollicité interviewé
par samia de sheer voilà comment elle
elle imagine la compensation même
manière quand on a supprimé la taxe
d'habitation
on a compensé à l'euro près les
collectivités qui avant lui percevait et
donc on l'a trouvée parce que l'état a
su faire des économies mais a su sur son
budget et bien compenser ces pertes pour
les collectivités locales c'est la même
chose en aucun cas on ne veut fragiliser
le dieu grec nous allons garantir les
ressources de l'audiovisuel public ça
veut dire deux mots ça veut dire
garantir le niveau des ressources de
l'audiovisuel public qui doit pouvoir
continuer à exister pour faire vivre le
pluralisme de l'information et d'autre
part la question de la pérennité de ces
ressources nous est logique de
programmation pluriannuelle de manière à
ce qu'on donne de la visibilité à
l'audiovisuel
christophe koszarek on vous a pas encore
entendu dans ce débat est ce que ce que
ce que jean marc dumontet disais à
l'instant où ce que berger a donné comme
précision à samia déchire ce que ça vous
rassure
oui c'est plutôt rassurant effectivement
il faut du reste qu'on garde en tête
quand même des objectifs
l'essentiel c'est quoi sans les contenus
ce qu'il faut c'est sanctuarisé des
financements des contenus pourquoi parce
que derrière tout ça on a des
téléspectateurs on a des consommateurs
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent c'est assez
basique qui veulent des contenus
puissant on veut lutter quand les
plateformes de s vod américaine pour
cela il faut des contenus puissant il
faut pouvoir financer ces contenus il
faut des talents vous savez si netflix
ou amazon réussissent à capter autant
d'abonnés ce n'est pas parce qu'il filme
il propose des séries filmées par des
téléphones portables c'est parce qu'il
propose des séries puissante il propose
des contenus puissants et ils
investissent des centaines de millions
de dollars dans ses comptes nuit vont
chercher les meilleurs talents pour
ensuite les proposer aux consommateurs
la télévision doit pouvoir se défendre
at élisant public doit pouvoir se
défendre et donc elle doit pouvoir
proposer des contenus qui sont puissants
qui sont inédits parce que c'est ce que
réclament les téléspectateurs puis
derrière tout ça il ya aussi tout un
alors d'abord c'est pour la défense de
notre souveraineté culturelle puis
derrière il ya il ya un tout un tissu
d'entreprises il ya des emplois et puis
c'est dans la tradition française aussi
de faire rayonner notre pays à travers
notre culture à travers notre création
et si vous regardez un petit peu ce qui
se passe dans les pays européens vous
avez des vous avez beaucoup de beaucoup
de chaînes publiques prenez l'angleterre
par exemple qui sont très bien financées
même mieux financer que la télévision
publique française et ils s'investissent
énormément dans les contenus ils font
rayonner la création anglaise en
exportant leurs contenus donc on se doit
de de garder vraiment est un élément
essentiel c'est la défense de notre
souveraineté culturelle et ça passe par
des contenus ça passe par le financement
des contenus parce que les
téléspectateurs ils attendent ça ils
attendent des contenus inédits des
contenus puissant on l'a bien compris et
je reviens vers vous tout à l'heure
effectivement 1
un coup d'oeil sur ce qui se passe
ailleurs en europe notamment sur le
montant de la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public par foyer la suisse
et 328 euros par an l'allemagne on est à
220 la grande bretagne même si elle fait
plus partie de l'union est à 171 en
france en l'a dit 138 l'italie 90 le
portugal c'est 36 euros si on supprime
cette contribution la france devient
l'un des salles il ya l'espagne et les
pays bas qui n'ont pas de de redevance
audiovisuelle catherine morin desailly
je reviens à la question du jour vient à
la question du de la pérennité le l'idée
d'un financement pluriannuel d'une loi
plus raide mais est ce que ça vous
suffit que ça
c'est une idée mais tout ça il subit
quand même à la nullité budgétaire donc
le parlement chaque année à l'assemblée
nationale comme au sénat doit approuver
voilà les propositions de dépenses
secteur par secteur qui lui sont faites
donc forcément il donc on peut avoir un
effet un financement sur cinq ans mais
mais tous les ans le remettre en cause
ce sont exactement au gré des aléas
budgétaires auxquelles un gouvernement
doit faire face
a compris que la situation budgétaire de
l'état n'est pas allé pas brillante qui
va y avoir aussi un certain nombre de
priorités dans les années à venir donc
forcément ça inquiète le secteur de
l'audiovisuel est derrière tout le
secteur de vielles au secteur de la
création et du cinéma parce que c'est
beaucoup d'emplois induits derrière
derrière tout cela donc la disparition
comme ça a été dit du tass affecté est
inquiétant et fragilise quoi qu'on en
dise l'audiovisuel public et d'ailleurs
c'est aussi toute la différence entre ce
qu'est une dotation publique c'est à
dire une ressource une part de l'impôt
qui est directement affecté taxe
affectée d'une ligne budgétaire défini
dans le cas d'un budget de l'état chaque
année la dotation publique est très
différente de la dotation d'état et dans
le cadre de la dotation publique sa
garantie une pérennité un dilemme issn
de la ressource est aussi une
indépendance puisqu'il n'y a pas
d'analysé budgétaire donc il ya cette
préoccupation là à quoi voilà on
substitue
la c ap et d'ailleurs je trouve annoncé
ça comme une mesure favorable au pouvoir
d'achat c'est un peu démagogique
pardonnez moi parce que la dépense au
bout du compte ça sera toujours le
budget de l'état l'obligé de la nation
il repose sur quoi ils reposent sur
l'impôt quoi qu'il arrive donc il repose
sur le contribuable donc je crois qu'il
faut raison garder surtout quand on
évalue le montant la redevance
aujourd'hui c'est aux difficultés 5
euros par mois aux gars de scout un
abonnement ou netflix business puce
amazon prime donc on peut aussi avoir
des éléments de contexte est intéressant
de réfléchir à tout ça on en a pour
notre argent voilà
c'est ce qu'on peut se pose la critique
mais il ya toutes ces questions derrière
y'en a pas qu'eux mais y en a mais je
rappelle d'ailleurs que public sénat est
financé à 100% sur le budget du sénat
donc nous on n'est pas concerné par la
question de la redevance jean marc
dumontet démagogie
on peut penser toujours que dans une
campagne électorale des baisses de
fiscalité annoncées sont démagogiques ça
a été simplement un leitmotiv
du président on le voit avec la taxe
d'habitation qui est une mesure
extrêmement forte et cet accompagnement
au fond on achève avec la
cette phase avec la redevance
constitue une volonté affichée du
président d'essayer de baisser la
fiscalité il l'a fait pour les
entreprises il l'a fait pour les ménages
il l'a fait pour les particuliers il
compte bien falloir continuer si bien
évidemment au but bien évidemment mais
il n'a jamais été question de ne pas
continuer à financer l'audiovisuel
public jamais ça bien mais pas forcément
jouer juste te dire quelque chose sur la
cour pour répondre à ce qu'a dit aurore
bergé sur la compensation fait à la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
alors non mais c'est important parce que
la compensation aux collectivités
territoriales pour les communes ça a été
la fellation la taxe sur le foncier bâti
donc alors c'est pas notre débat
elle étend rapidement il ya un principe
de libre administration des
collectivités territoriales ya un
principe d'indépendance de l'audiovisuel
public dans son sa conception européenne
bien sûr donc en fonction de la taxe
affectée on va garantir ou non la libre
administration de la livre oui la libre
indépendante on parle on parlera de
l'indépendance évidemment même mathieu
gallet voilà je vais vous dire ce que ce
que j'ai ressenti en entendant le
président de la république lundi soir
bon j'ai d'abord été un peu surpris mais
ensuite je me suis dit mais j'ai
l'impression qu'ils s'achètent une
polémique par an voyez ce que je veux
dire parce que chaque année la question
du budget de l'audiovisuel public ce
rapport sera sera posée est ce que
l'état met autant d'argent l'année
précédente pourquoi elle mais pourquoi
l'état mais éventuellement un peu moins
que l'année précédente c'était avec
cette réforme on ouvre la boîte de
pandore il faut le dire là aussi je
reviens une expérience ancien quand
nicolas sarkozy a supprimé à partir de
2009 la publicité après 20 heures sur
france télévisions c'était 450 millions
d'euros qui devait être compensé à
l'euro près c'est le même robert g est
d'ailleurs à a utilisé la même la même
formule la première année ça a été vrai
l'état via le budget général de l'état à
compenser dès la deuxième année bercy
n'a pas suivi la trajectoire qui était
prévu et les années suivantes en plus et
quand je suis arrivé à radio france en
2014 j'ai eu effectivement à devoir
gérer un budget en baisse parce qu'on
avait donné plus de redevances à france
télévisions pour compenser la baisse de
la dotation budgétaire et donc on
enlever aux autres entreprises alina à
radio france arte france médias montrent
donc en fait on a on a le fait d'avoir
introduit cette notion de dotation
budgétaire est venu tous les ans
créée en fait un débat parlementaire et
c'est bien la démocratie donc tous les
ans on aura un débat tous les ans on
aura des amendements qui viendront
d'intérêts particuliers d'intérêts
catégoriels qui viendront dire et poussé
avec un lobbying efficace pour certains
dire mais là quand même cette émission
où la cette mission on devrait revenir
donc tous les ans effectivement il va y
avoir un débat au parlement parce que
c'est une règle constitutionnelle on
peut s'engager sur cinq ans mais tous
les ans le de la loi de finances est
votée par le parlement donc pour moi on
ouvre la boîte de pandore et j'ai envie
de dire on va pas assez loin parce que
ce ne parler que du financement et ne
pas parler de la réforme du périmètre et
des missions c'est faire du rustine âge
et donc moi je pense que le
président-candidat ouvre un débat
intéressant mais qu'il faut aller au
bout et maintenant se dire c'est quoi
l'émission c'est quoi le périmètre du
l'audiovisuel public parce que je ne
crois pas je vous mets mon billet je ne
crois pas que dans cinq ans le niveau de
financement sera celui qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui parce que l'état est assis
sur 2800 milliards de dettes et que ça
va pas s'améliorer avec les problèmes
qu'on a en ce moment il faudra bien
rembourser un moment donc les
suppressions d'un pot il faudra bien les
compenser jean marc dumontet sûr alors
il ya beaucoup d'éléments dans ce que
mathieu gaye vient de nous dire mais
d'abord sur la question de de
l'indépendance et du soupçon de contrôle
j'ai juste décision si chaque année
pourra revenir voyez ce que je veux dit
mathieu gallet qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est que jusqu'à présent
avec la redevance ça n'empêchait pas des
arbitrages et que une lisa lui-même subi
donc ça veut dire que la redevance
c'était absolument pas la garantie parce
qu'il ya une dotation budgétaire non non
c'est parce qu'il y avait la
compensation budgétaire met d'accord
mais
il y avait des amis parce qu'il y avait
50 euros de dotation budgétaire qui
s'est renié par bercy et c'est ça qui
venait créer cette incertitude est
requis donc donc il y avait déjà des
arbitrages à ses premiers points le
deuxièmement point on vous l'avait
évoqué tout à l'heure 600 millions en
compensation pour tous les foyers qui ne
payent pas là aussi c'était un acte un
acte fort qui pouvait être à chaque
moment discuter à chaque moment 18h
chaque moment rogner ne l'a pas été oui
mais là ce troisième mentalité du budget
pardonnez-moi pardonnez moi
troisièmement le président a demandé à
l'audiovisuel public un certain nombre
d'efforts pendant ce mandat parce qu'à
des contrats d'objectifs et chaque année
on rend des comptes fallait les grands
opérateurs absolument pas respectée
rendez compte c'est quand il ya eu il ya
eu excusez moi il ya eu un grand plan
d'économies sur france télévisions et
des économies qui ont été accomplis et
eu un redéploiement fort sur l'amérique
une accélération sur le numérique donc
ces objectifs ont été
satisfaits et quand en période de crise
que nous avons vécue l'audiovisuel
public a eu besoin
d'être soutenus il a été soutenu donc je
répète la volonté du président c'est pas
de casser l'audiovisuel public
l'audiovisuel public et doit poursuivre
comme n'importe quelle entreprise samu
et encore plus dans dans le moment où
vit avec l'irruption totale du numérique
qui change complètement la donne donc il
ya des évolutions qui vont se produire
mais il n'y a aucune remise en cause
parce qu'on en a besoin c'est juste
c'est juste important ce métier on a
besoin d'un audiovisuel public fort en
termes de création en termes
d'information et ce serait suicidaire
d'aller imaginer qu'on va mettre en
l'air le service public on a
particulièrement besoin en termes
d'information notamment d'une
information plurielle qui ne soit pas
entre les mains de quelques-uns je n'ai
pas offert de deux schémas ou pointer
quelques dangers que nous rencontrons
aujourd'hui on en a besoin d'autant plus
ce serait totalement ridicule que
l'audiovisuel public aujourd'hui
rencontre des grands succès bon si je
ris en audio oui et grand succès en
terme de jeu obtenu que je reprends la
main pouvoir comment le sénat a réagi et
quentin calmet peut nous rejoindre parce
que yahia il y avait déjà évidemment
beaucoup de réflexions autour du
financement et de l'avenir de
l'audiovisuel public exactement et en
plus les sénateurs qui ont annoncé une
nouvelle mission justement sur cette
question de la redevance ils ont annoncé
hier parce qu'on a vu en fait à une
levée de boucliers quasi générale au
sénat lorsqu'emmanuel macron a
effectivement proposé la suppression la
redevance télé à l'image du sénateur
socialiste david assouline qui a parlé
dans un tweet de démagogie dangereuse et
d'une suppression qui serait grave pour
l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel puis
quand on y revient encore la question de
l'indépendance de cette audience
publique qui inquiète également le
président votre successeur un de la
commission des de la culture laurent
lafon il a dit en remplaçant une recette
qui lui était attribuée par une
ressource budgétaire l'audiovisuel
public sera encore plus dépendant des
décisions du gouvernement surtout que
cette suppression en fait tout va le
comprendre elle va dans le sens inverse
de ce que prône proposé le sénat en 2015
lorsque et bien le sénat à travailler
sur ce financement de l'audiovisuel
public qui proposait une contribution
forfaitaire universel l'idée était donc
non pas de supprimer la redevance mais
de l'élargir non plus en contrepartie
d'un service rendu ou conditionné à la
détention d'un récepteur elle serait
ainsi
obligatoire dans chaque lieu de
résidence comme vous le voyez dans cet
extrait du rapport de l'époque les
sénateurs prenait l'exemple de
l'allemagne qui a mis en place un tel
système le 1er janvier 2013 à l'époque
c'est un forfait de 18 euros par mois
soit 216 euros par an et donc que vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure ça atteint
depuis 2019 la somme de 220 euros cette
contribution 1 good food by track
rapporte désormais milliards d'euros or
cette voie là de recettes pour
l'audiovisuel allemand et donc nous
verrons est si effectivement les
sénateurs prôneront à nouveau et bien
cette contribution généralisée puisque
les sénateurs commencent leurs auditions
la semaine prochaine les deux
rapporteurs c'est roger karoutchi est
vraiment hugo merci round phuc beitrag
merci c'était le défi du jour pour
quentin calme est prononcé en allemand
c'est je voudrais vous entendre sur eux
sur les effectivement ce que le sénat
avait en tête parce que c'était vraiment
là ça semble en tout cas la logique
inversée au contraire élargir
le financement en et en élargissant
l'assiette en quelques secondes c'est
élargir l'assiette puisque je rappelle
que le les nouveaux usages et les
nouveaux supports forcément on conduit
l'ensemble des pays en europe à réformer
l'assiette de leurs redevances et la
france est le dernier pays en fait à ne
pas avoir fait cette réforme de la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public que
de longue date nous jugions nécessaire
au sein de la commission et que en effet
nous arrivons au bout du bout puisqu'il
ya la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation et la redevance est adossé
à la taxe d'habitation forcément se pose
la question de la suppression
concomitante de la redevance et son côté
quelque peu obsolète puisqu'elle ne
correspond plus tout à fait aux usages
donc de toute façon il ya une réforme et
moi je regrette que cette réforme elle
n'est pas été fait concomitamment à la
réforme qui aurait dû être votée au
printemps dernier parce qu'on aurait
comme l'a dit mathieu gallet on aurait
regardé l'ensemble c'est un tout
l'audiovisuel public ce sont des
missions c'est un périmètre c'est une
organisation c'est une gouvernance et
c'est un modèle économique et si nous
avions eu ce débat devant la
représentation nationale et devant les
français on peut considérer que la
campagne présidentielle ça peut être
aussi le moment de poser ce débat je
suis assez fan mais ne coupez pas jouer
terminé s'il vous plaît mon propos c'est
important et donc je pense c'est pour ça
que je dis ne faut pas voir les choses
par le petit bout de la lorgnette et là
mathieu gallet de la dic comme moi ah
non c'est simplement les mesures
financières sans parler du reste tout
est lié de quais l'audiovisuel public
parlant nous qu'est l'audiovisuel public
voulons nous moi je vais vous dire
quelque chose je j'observe que
l'audiovisuel extérieur calme un peu
plus d'une dizaine d'années fait un
travail extraordinaire et que
l'audiovisuel extérieur aujourd'hui
c'est un enjeu stratégique majeur pour
la france pour l'europe la guerre en
ukraine nous le montre tous les jours
pourquoi aujourd'hui on ne dit pas oui
il faudrait faire quelque chose cette
audiovisuel extérieur n'a peut-être pas
assez de moyens d'accord on regarde bien
compris j'essaye de distribuer la parole
le plus équitablement possible propos
important si vous avez reçu rien
alimenter le débat lors jean marc
dumontet will you réagir on est en
campagne électorale
donc c'est le bon moment il avantage
c'est que le président pose cette
question même si je vous répète c'était
une question autour du pouvoir d'achat
il a encore décliné exsangue il dribble
bien ce que ça ouvrait comme il est dur
mais ces jeux c'est important de
recentrer sur ça on ouvre le débat qui
va mettre et qui a mis ce sujet sur la
table c'est le président c'est le
président il n'est pas réélu s'il n'est
pas contre la libye quand ses mérites
zemmour
suite aux propos d'eric zemmour il ya eu
un débat dans le pays non aujourd'hui ce
débat une s'ouvre c'est une campagne
électorale c'est le moment opportun ce
sera peut-être autour du parlement si le
président est élu pour un nouveau mandat
la question est posée c'est extrêmement
démocratique à moitié en fait moi je
trouve que ce cette proposition elle est
assez fidèle au fond au maquereau nisme
d'origine
macron il s'est fait élire contre
l'économie de la rente toutes les
rendent possibles imaginables et d'une
certaine façon la relance est une rente
pour l'audiovisuel public mais le
problème c'est que il aborde le la
problématique par la question fiscale et
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas le débat qui
suit il s'en va après parce qu'il a
d'autres d'autres affaires à régler sur
la scène diplomatique
donc on a juste le début du commencement
du débat et qui se tient un peu sans lui
pour l'instant et moi il ya un mot qui
manque je trouve et qu'on peut parler
périmètre on peut parler gouvernance on
peut parler indépendance on peut par
émission on parle jamais qualité qu'est
ce qui fait la spécificité du sel de
l'audiovisuel public c'est un sujet
tabou vous entendrez jamais que des gens
se dire bah oui mais ça c'est pas bien
c'est je vous pose une question est ce
qu'il est et dans la mission de
l'audiovisuel public ou jupes tall a
tourné différemment et ce qu'eric
zemmour existerait aujourd'hui tel qu'il
est si l'audiovisuel public ne lui est
pas fourni une tribune à une dans des
émissions à très grande écoute pour
proférer toutes ces provocations qui ont
fait ce qu'ils aient aujourd'hui qui
était à l'époque chargé de faire du buzz
est de faire de l'audience pour cette
émission est ce que c'est bien une
mission de service public
je réponds pas à la
liberté d'expression alors oui voilà des
citoyens un moment et on peut considérer
qu'elle exhibe où on n'a pas la
reconnaissance du
ventre pardon puisque aujourd'hui sont
privés enfin privatif et france inter là
christophe koszarek je voudrais juste
savoir ce que ce que ça représente
france télévisions aujourd'hui en
matière de financement de la création
parié des contenus tout à l'heure c'est
quoi c'est le premier financeur c'est le
deuxième il se sait quoi l'importance de
français les millions partenaire des
deux du monde de la création des
producteurs indépendants
on ne peut pas laisser enfin on peut pas
se baser uniquement sur sur deux marchés
pour pour financer des contenus français
pourquoi parce que vous avez des chaînes
commerciales qui
répondent à des critères purement
purement financière économique c'est
normal elle cherche à être rentable plus
rentable possible on va pas leur faire
ce reproche donc
on a besoin d'avoir un autre partenaire
qui est la télévision publique un
partenaire fort un partenaire qui qui
qui soit capable de financer des
contenus puissant et d'accompagner tout
le monde de la création vous savez
encore une fois il faut vraiment garder
en tête que si on affaiblit le le soft
power c'est le c'est à dire le monde de
la création parce que on affaiblit le
financement des contenus et bien on à
faiblir à notre souveraineté culturelle
et il faut ne faut pas oublier que les
téléspectateurs ils attendent qu'une
chose c'est d'avoir des contenus
puissant et des contenus inédits voilà
et si on
met en danger le financement des
contenus alors ça se fera ressentir non
seulement sur toute la chaîne de la de
la création mais également auprès des
téléspectateurs qui se retrouvent et se
tourneront vers soi les chaînes
commerciales soient des plateformes
américaines pour répondre à
l'interrogation de matthieu croissandeau
à l'instant
est-ce que vous produisez des programmes
différents parce que c'est pour le
service public des programmes que vous
produisez actuellement pour le privé
voilà une bien sûr d'un village une
exigence qui n'est pas la mienne me
connaît thomas vous me connaissez bien
je suis un fervent défenseur de
l'identité de et de l'intérêt d'un
service public de l'audiovisuel
et bien sûr que la télévision publique
est différente des chaînes commerciales
elle propose des programmes très
différents des émissions citoyenne elle
propose des émissions politiques des
documentaires voilà toutes sortes de
problèmes du théâtre des programmes que
vous ne verrez pas sur les chaînes
commerciales à tout son intérêt et c'est
bien pour cela qu'il faut la défendre
c'est bien pour ça qu'il faut
réfléchir à
au périmètre du visuel public pourquoi
pas réfléchir à ces missions pourquoi
pas mais il ne faut pas mettre en danger
le financement des contenus c'est ça
l'essentiel
j'ai quand même une question et je vais
peut-être la peine imposée à jean-marc
remontée puisqu'il est il à côté de moi
ça va être quand même la question de la
publicité sur le service public à un
moment ou un autre ce qu'on la regarde
peu après 20h jeu on va devoir faire des
économies dans ce pays dont les années à
venir via ce tout le monde le sait le
quoi qu'il en coûte même si hélas la
situation actuelle va probablement nous
amener à garder cette politique là pour
un certain temps un moment il va falloir
quand même qu'on rembourse ne serait-ce
que les intérêts de la dette française
donc il va bien falloir faire des
arbitrages et donc le sujet c est ce que
la présence de la publicité à france
télévisions notamment soirée où pendant
des grands événements sportifs on a les
jo de 2024 qui arrive à paris est ce que
la question va être ouverte de remettre
de la publicité à certains moments à
certains endroits sur france télévision
parce qu'on aura besoin de trouver des
recettes et on a maintenu france 4 il
faut le rappeler quand même pendant la
crise duco vide alors qu'il y avait la
prévision de supprimer france 4 pour
faire des économies donc le président la
république lui même a souhaité que
france 4 soit maintenu sa prévision et
doit donc tenir compte d'une chose au
service public on lui demande de se
réformer et d'où va venir ce financement
si on ne fait pas une vraie révolution
sur le périmètre et sur la structure de
l'audiovisuel public qu'est ce que vous
en pensez faut-il ou tout simplement
rétablir la publicité après 20 heures
c'est vrai que la question des
programmes sportifs c'est intéressant
parce que les droits coûte de plus en
plus cher donc considéré légitime d'y
insérer des publicités je plaide pour
l'agilité l'ouverture et
il faut qu'on arrête d'être dans des
schémas établis et qu'ils ne bougeraient
pas vous parler des droits sportifs pour
la première fois france télé a partagé
avec amazon les droits sportifs enfin
sur roland garros
il ya eu des économies pendant ce mandat
avec des résultats magnifiques france
télé sur le redéploiement et en termes
d'audience donc il faut sortir du
dogmatisme
il faut être ouvert je suis incapable de
vous dire si demain le retour de la
publicité après 20 heures sera une
proposition où sera la règle en trois
ans je n'en sais strictement rien je
pense qu'il faut être agile vous faire
confiance aussi au service public pour
être agile et pour continuer son
développement voilà sans dogmatisme sans
dogmatisme et il faut maintenir cette
exigence et je vous rejoins parfaitement
faut maintenir cette exigence et se dire
c'est quoi le service public en quoi il
se distingue et quelle est sa véritable
mission et comment il la rend les
clients repenser comment il aurait pu
bien avoir le temps dans cette campagne
si particulière de s'engager sur cette
question là et finalement peut-être il
ne restera que vous voyez ce que je veux
dire la proposition fiscale c'est un
risque quand même le président aura le
loisir au travers de son programme
connurent d'en parler vous ne pouvez pas
ouvrir un tel débat ne pas apporter des
réponses on l'espère sur la publicité je
voulais revenir sur france 4 qu'on a
évoqué je tiens à dire que le sénat
était très moteur dans l'intérêt
francecap tâche est de la jeunesse parce
que quand l'annoncent comme ça ex nihilo
faire des économies a été annoncée sans
raison aucune la suppression de 2 france
4 on s'est aperçu que derrière c'était
tout le secteur aussi je me tourne vers
représentants dont le sénateur on sait
bien juste tous secteurs de l'animation
qui étaient menacés derrière voilà
france 4 a fait ses preuves pendant
confinement ont été bien contents de
trouver une chute de la jeunesse la
chaîne dite apprenantes qui a déployé
beaucoup d'efforts en matière de
programme citoyen éducatif et qui a fait
ses preuves c'est la raison pour
laquelle france 4 a été maintenue je
rappelle que les le sénat a proposé la
suppression de la publicité sur france
cap pour qui un espace complètement
sanctuariser pour que la jeunesse elles
ne subissent pas voilà les annonceurs
publicitaires matin midi et soir à
l'heure de la publicité ciblée sur les
plateformes c'est quand même intéressant
d'avoir un espace autorisez vous pouvez
vous mettre vos gamins vous êtes sûr
voilà qui seront pas bombardés d'offres
publicité dont je tiens à dire qu'il ya
une réponse et c'est la différenciation
aussi de service public ont parlé de la
qualité c'est ce qui fait aussi la
différenciation avec les chaînes
commerciales je tiens à l'actualité
aussi sur les chaînes pour voir ça il ya
des contenus puissance en chaîne privée
je trouve ce débat quand même assez
ahurissant sur tout le monde loue
netflix et mange dcns freaks à n'en plus
finir c'est une niche dans une plate
forme privée me méfierais aussi mathieu
viannay
des coups il ya des programmes que le
service public peut mettre à l'antenne
que des chaînes privées ne mettrait pas
partie des chaînes moins d'audience qui
aurait misé un kopeck sur un programme
de cuisine comme top chef par exemple
qui a fait beaucoup pour la gastronomie
française beaucoup pour l'apprentissage
dans les cuisines et qui viennent une
chaîne privée
qui font des programmes de grande
qualité hpi qui est quand même le plus
grand succès l'année dernière d'une
série française mêmes qui se classe sur
les premières audiences c'est sur tf1
d'où viens je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
fait de dire que le service public fait
des choses qui sont différentes vues du
privé moi je trouve que la qualité de ce
que fait privé c'est beaucoup augmenté a
beaucoup augmenté ces derniers temps
probablement parce qu'on a un service
public fort et qui rencontre un vrai
succès et qui tire tout le monde vers le
haut et ça vaut aussi pour la radio
parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé on
est forcément mon coeur est toujours un
peu du côté de radio france et quand on
voit les succès de france inter on va
dire que voilà la radio publique
aujourd'hui il a aussi fait une vraie
différence par rapport par rapport à
l'ensemble de l'offre radiophonique
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat ici et et en duplex c'était
passionnant ce